my name is Andrew Stevens I've just
moderated the reinvigorating the
Millennium Development Goals we had vice
president of international Jeffrey Sachs
and the head of th development that
would magic replicated development make
what what the panel focused on heavily
was the need for more public-private
partnership in developing achieving the
global believe millennium development
goals are also it can plus quite clearly
that there needs to be more leadership
shown in this region like governments to
actually push the agenda for
environmental issues particularly big a
major sustainable environmental
development is something that concerns
area being leader MVC's which is
something that's where is falling behind
here poverty reduction though still very
strong without leading the world in
anything like